[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARJITA SETHI: Welcome back
to Public Speaking Pro
Tips with Speechless presented
by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into memorable.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Challenges into insights.
ARJITA SETHI: And presentations
into performances.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And we
do that with something we
call improv thinking.
ARJITA SETHI:
Today, we are going
to help Claire come up with
a company [INAUDIBLE] script
while we walk between meetings.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
So I just found out
that I have to say a little
something about myself
tomorrow at a meeting, and
I have absolutely no time
to prepare for it.
ARJITA SETHI: So
let's do something
we call elevator pitch.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: All right.
Let's do it.
ARJITA SETHI: Now tell me, what
are you going to talk about?
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Well,
that's the thing.
I have no idea.
ARJITA SETHI: Well, if you're
just introducing yourself
to the team, just pick
one thing that stands out
and focus on that.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Well, I did
recently moved to Los Angeles.
ARJITA SETHI: Perfect.
Talk about that.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Right now?
ARJITA SETHI: Right now.
You have only 10
more floors to go.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Oh, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Excuse me.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
I'm Claire Slattery
and I'm a Speechless specialist.
It's great to be back
in San Francisco.
I loved living here
for 4 and 1/2 years.
But last year, I
decided to make the move
to Hollywood-- you know,
because I like wearing shorts
every day of the year.
And also, I'm a professional
actor-- no big deal.
And as much as I love
me some San Francisco,
I can't win an Emmy doing
commercials for startups--
unless I can, in
which case, I'm moving
back immediately because I
really miss the burritos.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, great.
But you rambled a bit.
Tell me the story again, but
now you have only five more
floors to go.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Fair enough.
Hi, I'm Claire Slattery and
I'm a Speechless specialist
based in LA.
It's great to be
back in the Bay Area.
But as much as I love
me some San Francisco,
I can't win an Emmy doing
commercials for startups--
unless I can, in which case,
I'm coming back immediately.
ARJITA SETHI: OK, time's up.
That was great.
I'll send you the audio files.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Audio files?
ARJITA SETHI: Yep, I
recorded the entire thing.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Oh.
ARJITA SETHI: Basically,
you TimeBox your talk
so that you can get the general
outline out of your month.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Wow, I love that.
ARJITA SETHI: Yep,
starting the script
is a lot of times
the hardest part.
But giving a presentation is
something you do by speaking,
ultimately.
So why not just start speaking?
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Makes a lot of sense.
ARJITA SETHI: Doesn't it?
It's what we call on
your feet first draft.
And with elevator pitch, you can
expand and contract your talk
based on how much time
you either have to prepare
or how long the
talk needs to be.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: So
how long were those?
ARJITA SETHI:
Well, the first one
was about 10 floors--
I mean, 30 seconds.
And the second one-- 15 seconds.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Good to know.
So what do I do now?
ARJITA SETHI: Just
listen back to the files
and keep iterating on the talk.
You can TimeBox and
record yourself.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: But wait
a second, what's TimeBox?
ARJITA SETHI: It's
just an alarm that
allows you to know when to
move onto your next task.
Let's say you only want to
spend 30 minutes on your talk.
You set the timer and then
record your rehearsals,
and keep improving it.
When your timer goes off,
you put the last touches
on what you want to finish.
And you might never have to
sit down and write anything.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: You have
just saved me, Arjita.
I really thought I
was going to have
to cancel dinner plans with a
friend and work on this speech
all night.
But basically, we have
it outlined before lunch.
ARJITA SETHI: And
Claire, you can't
win an Emmy doing commercials,
but you could win a Clio.
See you later.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Now you tell me.
Now it's your turn.
Go ahead and make a video with
your one-minute elevator pitch.
Then do it in 30 seconds,
15 seconds, and finally
just one word.
Not only do you have the
outline for the longer version,
but you also have the
keyword for your whole talk.
We like to think of it
as your mantra word.
After you make your
elevator pitch,
post it to social with the
hashtag #DevelopYourVoice.
And remember to check the
description below for links
from the Google Developers,
Women Techmakers, and more tips
from Speechless on how to
think like an improviser
and develop your voice.
[ELEVATOR BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]